sumaya he'll mosses husband disappeared
without a trace
eight months ago after months of anxious
searching she was suddenly informed that
he's in police custody in the Turkish
capital Ankara she was allowed to visit
him briefly and was very shocked when
she saw him he'd lost a lot of weight at
least 20 kilos his face was pale and his
hands were ice-cold
I guess he wasn't given enough food I
was kept in a place without daylight on
the 19th of February 20 1954 mas said
goodbye to his wife like every morning
but he never came back
he walked towards the bus stop on the
pavement but before he arrived two men
ambushed him they threw a black bag over
his head I assumed he was forced into a
black transporter that was waiting on
the corner and then driven away some of
this was caught on a local businesses
surveillance camera it's the only proof
sumaya has that her husband was
kidnapped a few months before he'd been
briefly detained on suspicion of
supporting the Gulen movement that's
accused of being behind the attempted
coup in 2016
none of her letters received an answer
she did eventually receive some support
from the opposition MP Umaga Giglio glue
he says that the case of Sameach Gilliam
as his husband is not unique
he's been informed of at least 28 such
kidnappings so far very few journalists
turned up at a press conference he
called this is a very sensitive subject
in Turkey since many of those who have
disappeared are suspected of being
supporters of the Gulen movement few
people are willing to stand up for them
in public this man is a trade unionist
he said he was almost kidnapped in
September he filmed himself making a
statement and posted a photo of a black
transporter but now he's afraid to talk
to the media he's right to feel afraid
each time the MP Ummah Giglio blue goes
out on the street with samayal mosques
and other relatives to draw attention to
those who have disappeared the police
intervene and break up the gathering we
contacted the Turkish authorities to
find out more we asked the Ministry of
the Interior for a statement via the
Turkish embassy in Berlin but to no
avail
international human rights groups have
not received any information about the
disappearances from the Turkish
authorities either they can only
speculate as to why the government has
resorted to such ruthless methods
overall it's very difficult to explain a
kind of rational reason for doing this
which isn't based on a desire to either
frighten the rest of the population or
to extract information from those men or
make those men confess to crimes which
perhaps they didn't commit some of those
who've been abducted and later released
have found the courage to talk about
what they experienced publicly to help
other victims and their relatives
[Music]
one man wrote a letter describing how he
had been tortured in a secret location
probably run by the Turkish Secret
Service's yep but if you don't confess
they say we will torture you to die we
will bury you somewhere that'll make it
look as if it was a natural death a few
witnesses there are all say the same
thing they were kidnapped by a black
transporter blindfolded and taken to a
building with several cells where there
are also other people and they were
tortured repeatedly so that they would
give up names mayor mas is convinced her
husband was tortured too
now he's accused of being a member of an
armed group he was not allowed the
lawyer of his choice sumaya and her
parents-in-law have sought advice from a
human rights association she says that
the police advised her to keep quiet so
as not to worse than her husband
situation but she refuses to be silenced
he's exquisite to tell from his physical
and mental state that my husband had had
a rough time I presume that he confessed
to a crime under torture and then he was
given some time to recover before being
taken to a police station Sameach Hill
mas now knows where her husband is but
not what will happen to him her worries
are far from over